well live in Vietnam and Hanoi for the
historic summit coming up this week all
right everybody on my staff crew they're
all laughing at this so I figured I'm
gonna share it takes a little courage to
do this but my commute to the set today
we might not have made it unless I got
out of a car and did this take a look
yes that's our commute early this
morning Emma it was you know we left at
7:15 a.m. it's almost 10 a.m. here but
10 p.m. in DC and just as Kim jong-un
arrived traffic was insane it was still
a standstill over 45 minutes so all
right we go Plan B then I hopped on the
scooter with somebody and I just went on
the sidewalk we got here on time
definitely interesting chaotic